Hello, can you hear me?
Tastin, Tastin, I'm currently holding in my hand right now because I need to be able
to police you down in between my thighs as an amazing thank you for the milestone.
And I'm really appreciative for everyone who subscribes and likes and enjoys.
And I just realized I'm wearing leggings.
So this ASMR isn't going to work. I'm going to need to take these off.
I don't know if I should edit this part out.
I'm currently standing up in my recording bag and that does me lowering my leggings.
Don't tell YouTube, I think you just heard my ankle crack as well.
That's my leggings around my ankles there.
Thank you very much for all of your support and I really appreciate it.
And now I'm going to see if I can put you in between my legs.
How does this sound?
Can you still hear me?
Am I crushing you?
I'm wondering. Actually, I might have to turn in this way in order to do it.
But my thigh pudge is going on you.
Ta-da!
Can you still breathe?
As long as you can still breathe, that's the main thing.
And you can tap out at any time.
Thomas!
Does it sound like anything?
Well, if you enjoy being in between my thighs,
then I'll just keep squishing you as a thank you.
I don't know if my voice would be muffled at all in here.
Or is this the part where I say thank you because you should be thanking me
for such an experience, shouldn't you?
You're so wonderfully loud.
Did my thigh sound nice and soft?
See, that's my skin.
You can tap it around your ears as well.
See?
So my thigh is cupping your ear and if I tap my thigh fat,
it's getting picked up on the ear.
What a strange experience for you.
I'm trying to see if you could hear my heartbeat through my thighs,
but I don't think my blood flow is as strong.
Answer me this.
Do you like being bloomy?
I feel like it makes such a good belly.
I can hate lopia because I have no strength in my arms or my wrists or my hands.
Almost strength is in my legs.
So I can technically do this for as long as I like.
You can pretend to struggle and try and get away, but good luck with art.
Good luck.
I'm glad you're getting good at knowing your place.
Okay, okay, I'll have a bit of a break.
Can't be meaty all the time, that cannot, unless you like it.
That's different.
Well, if you have no further objections, get back on your knees then.
How's that?
Are you starting to realize where you should be in life?
Yeah, I've walked right in between my thighs.
This is surprisingly nice on the muscles we should do this again sometime.
If you're ever feeling, you know, a bit pathetic,
at least you know you're safe to explore that side of you with me.
Because I don't judge.
No, not unless you want to.
That's different.
Because then I can judge you very hard.
Why?
I think I will let you be.
And I'll stop talking over your experience, because I'll probably ruin it.
I want you to get lost in your thoughts.
While I headlock you, okay?
You just let your mind run wild.
And think about all the scenarios.
And I'll say one last thing, that nothing is off limits.
Then go by then, good boy.
I'm sorry.